alguna vez se han preguntado qué es lo
que realmente hace un químico en esta
sección le pedimos a algunas personas
relacionadas con la química que nos
compartieran sus historias tenemos
personas de diferentes áreas y carreras
por ejemplo entrevistamos a alguien que
trabaja como forense que tiene mucho que
ver con la química analítica
también entrevistamos a personas que se
dedican a la ilustración científica
y a la medicina si alguna vez han
pensado en estudiar medicina o algo que
tenga que ver con eso seguramente ya
saben que tendrán algunas clases de
química también tenemos a alguien que
trabaja en la industria como
investigador y desarrolla nuevos
productos también tenemos a alguien que
incluso trabaja como programador en khan
academy y bueno tenemos muchas otras
entrevistas que aunque no pude encontrar
las imágenes son trabajos muy
interesantes como por ejemplo gente que
se ocupa en el campo de la ley de
patentes
la comunicación de la ciencia que tiene
que ver con la creación producción y
presentación de programas de televisión
también tenemos un ingeniero que no
tiene un grado en química pero ha tenido
que estudiarla porque es muy importante
para su trabajo
también tenemos un epidemiólogo que es
un poco difícil de pronunciar
epidemiólogo epidemiólogo
que también es una carrera muy
interesante y bueno tenemos muchos más y
con el tiempo esperamos seguir agregando
más entrevistas a la colección así que
revisen la sección de vez en cuando
espero que con esto se den una idea de
que todas estas personas que estudiaron
química hacen muchas cosas diferentes
así que hay muchas formas en las que
podemos usar la química como parte de
nuestra carrera aún después de terminar
la escuela espero que estas entrevistas
les gusten y sean útiles para ustedes y
les ayuden a saber que quieren hacer